محافظه ومنطقه مهمه ايضا بنسبه لكلى
المرشحين وهي العاصمه انقر فرح زمان انت
تتواجدين في تجمع انتخابي لمرشح المعارضه
كمال كيرشتار اوغلو الى الى جانب ملف
اللاجئين على ماذا تركز المعارضه في هذه
الساعات الاخيره قبل فتح صناديق الاقتراع
[موسيقى]
العناوين والدعوه للمشاركه ان اردت ان
ابدا للعناوين الانتخابيه يركز كل جدار
اولو على مساله اللاجئين كما قلت لانه
يستند كثيرا على وجود انت عاد من قبل
شريحه في الشارع التركي ويرى بان هذا
العنوان سيشد الناخب الى صندوقه ليقترع
لصالحه اتحد ايضا مع مع اخرين لتحقيق هذه
الغايه كما قال العنوان الثاني مساله
الاكراد هنا وكما يقول الاتهامات التي
وجهت له من قبل مرشح تحالف الجمهور رجب
طيب اردوغان بالقول بان كل جدار اوغلو
يتحالف مع الارهابيين على حد وصفه هنا
تكمن الاشاره في اعطائه وعود لحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكي يحصل على زعمه وعلى على
دعم الاحزاب اليساريه والاحزاب الكرديه
لاسيما في مناطق الشرق التركيه رد كل جدار
اولو سواء في العديد من الخطابات او في
تغريداته على تويتر على هذه المساله
تحديدا بقوله انه لا يتفاوض مع الارهابي
حاول التركيز على هذا الامر ليس فقط
ليحتفظ باصوات الاكراد الذين صوتوا لهم في
مناطقهم في الجوله الاولى وانما ايضا ياخذ
اصوات اخرين لم يصوتوا له عنوان ثالث جلال
الاقتصاد ومشاكله هناك في الشارع التركي
البطاله التضخم تراجع الليره التركيه امام
الدولار الامريكي كلها عناوين يقول
ان لم يتم تغيير اردوغان يتم التركيز هنا
على كلمه تغيير بمعنى ان اي خيار اخر كما
يقول الشارع الموالي للمعارضه قد يكون
افضل من المتاح حاليا على حد وصفهم ان لم
يحصل هذا التغيير فان هذه المشاكل ستبقى
ولا بل انها ستدهور اكثر فاكثر على حد
تعبير هنا ايضا جلال ما يتم التركيز عليه
هو المشاركه كلش ليس معنيا الان فقط
بتقريص بتقليص الفارق بينه وبين اردوغان
في الجوله الاولى والبالغ حوالي مليونين
ونصف مليون صوت فقط وانما هو ايضا معني
بالحصول على اصوات من لم يقترعوا في
الجوله الاولى من لم يختاروه في الجوله
الاولى حريص على ارضاء الاكراد من جهه
والقومين من جهه حريص على اجراء حريص على
ارضاء اطراف الطاوله السداسيه المعارضه
وهي عباره عن طيف من المتناقضات السياسيه
في الحقيقه هي مهمه ليست سهله جلال وعلى
هذا الاساس يحاول كل جدار اوغلو الان
الدعوه لمشاركه كثيفه الى جانب ذلك هو
يركز على العناوين يركز على ما يعتبره
اخفاقات لحكومه الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان اعتقد انه سيصل وسيبدا خطابه بعد
قليل في المكان الذي نتواجد فيه هنا ومن
المتوقع ان يركز على ذات النقاط التي
ذكرتها لك جلال